[Music]
it goes crazy drawing all these circles
hey i'm matt henderson i'm a research
scientist working on speech and language
processing um but in my spare time i
like making mathematical animations
this is slicing a cylinder and this is a
way to introduce the sine curve i've set
up
in mathematica something with a few
sliders if i lift this one here
you know you can see we have a cylinder
that's the establishing shot
and here
we're bringing in a plane to intersect
the cylinder so then the question is if
we're to
remove the top
and unroll the this part of the cylinder
what shape would you expect to get
and i obviously spoiled it by saying
we're getting a sine wave
originally i'd seen someone who'd taken
a toilet roll and they'd sliced it in
this way and then unrolled the the whole
thing and it just created this so
repeating sine wave for me i was a
little bit surprised to see oh yeah that
would be a sine wave and it's sort of
more of a natural way that that that
crops up
imagine that we have a point here and
this is going to be a bit like a point
in a pond with
with water rippling out from it in
concentric circles
and we'll also have these lines that are
coming across from left to right as we
get the
circles emanating from that point
they're going to meet with the lines
going from left to right and trace out a
curve so you can see that it's tracing
this curve
which is actually a parabola curve so
here we're still in a two-dimensional
world where the circles are growing and
the lines are moving all of a sudden
the camera has moved and we're revealing
that there's a 3d perspective of the
same thing
in the 3d world time is now
just another dimension going
down through the screen time is
basically this dimension going down
through the center of the cone or what
was originally like into the screen for
example as the lines were moving left to
right they're actually also moving down
and they're intersecting the circles and
the circles growing at a constant rate
through time
is the same as a cone
in this 3d picture here so what does it
mean to say that concentric circles in
the 2d world
meeting with lines forming is forming a
parabola what that means in the 3d
picture
is that if you slice a cone
at the right angle
then you'll get a parabola
so parabola is a
special conic section that's what you
call that
this one is titled a method to draw
infinitely many touching circles
catchy name yeah
it starts with a rectangle that we're
keeping a constant area and we're
interested in the patterns that that
draws as you move one of the corners of
the rectangle around you can see that
we're keeping this rectangle
for example here we're going to keep
this point of the rectangle fixed here
and we're going to move this one here it
starts off as a square and if as if we
move this one up
you can see that
uh this length has got longer and since
we're keeping the area constant at one
this length has to get shorter and where
if we move this one around this one's
are forced to be in a particular
location
the first thing that we'll do is we'll
cast
this point off
infinitely off to one side and off to
the other side and we'll see what
happens to this point here so now we're
going to
cast it off to the right and we'll start
drawing
so you can see this is moving along and
drawing
and
what's happening here well actually it's
drawing a circle
what i want to do is get a nice pattern
with lots and lots of circles inside
this original circle here
so if i was to draw that instead of
drawing a straight line i'm going to
draw a circle
so i'm going to start drawing circles in
this grid here
and see what happens to the point down
here so the the first circle
we're going to draw here
and you can see that it has corresponded
to a
circle down here
and it's touching the big circle because
this one is touching as well right now
let's draw another circle
drawing another circle at this point
now this one
is touching the original big circle
which is this line and this one here
so there's new circles touching
as you can see these two yeah so it's
kind of obvious how to draw
two circles that touch
a line up in this world
less less obvious the exact sort of
radius that you would need to for them
to fit snugly like that in that world
so you know just continue to keep
drawing circles up in this world up here
and now we're getting smaller circles
because they're more distant
we have the establishing shots of what's
happening
we draw the straight line which
corresponds to the circle and now we
just start drawing the circles above the
line
it goes crazy drawing all these circles
and zooming into the picture below
we get this intricate pattern
of um
infinitely many circles underneath what
this really is is a
is a geometrical construction called
circle inversion
amazing you'll never be able to look at
circles the same way the way that this
would be normally presented i think
is that you'd start with a circle that
simplify and say that the radius is one
i'm wondering where does this point get
mapped to
so this point will get mapped to
somewhere along
the line that connects
the center of the circle to that point
imagine that this distance is
r
it will get mapped to the point inside
the circle that's at distance one over r
and so you know there's a special point
here here r equals one over r
because the radius is is one
um anywhere inside
here will get mapped you know way out
here here it gets mapped like here and
so on and this has this property that
you know if i draw
if i draw a circle
in that picture then it turns into a
circle
outside
and and and also if you have a
if you have a straight line you know
like we had here
then this can be thought of as a
circle with an infinite radius
so it would correspond to
a circle down here that goes through the
center of that circle
the center of the circle gets mapped out
to infinity
i i like it because you know what i've
done is i've thought of a
geometrical reason for why how we could
keep this constraint of you know
mapping from r to one over r
and that is you know
in this picture if this is r
if this the long um side of the
rectangle's r then this has to be one
over r and that's just because we're
saying that the area has to equal one at
all times so it's kind of like a sneaky
way to say
to get all the nice properties of circle
inversion uh and you know one nice thing
you can do a circle inversion is create
these pretty pictures of infinitely many
circles touching each other and really
it's a trick
i didn't really do all the math to
figure out you know what radius and
where the centers of all these
complicated circles should be i just did
this
much more easy
grid structure on top
this episode was supported by kiwico
providers of these great subscription
crates an amazing hands-on way to get
excited about science technology
engineering the arts and mathematics
you've seen in the past that i love
making them but now i've started sending
them to my nephew sebastian on the other
side of the world and what a great
monthly gift to get from his uncle he
even sends me back videos so i can watch
the whole process after last month's
domino machine today's task is
manufacturing a walking
robot everything he needs is already in
the box
now kimiko has all sorts of boxes and
crates aimed at different age groups see
the website for more details about that
and they're already shipping to 40
countries you can get 50 off your first
box by using the url kiwico.com
number file it's in the description if
you want to click on that
like it kind of sets the human motion
there you go folks officially
awesome
[Music]